You said this place was steps from the water. We just haven't found the steps yet. How much did we save? Enough. Enough to get lost! Or you could book a stay with Hilton. Welcome to your oceanfront room. Just steps from the water.
你说这个地方离水边只有几步之遥。我们只是还没找到那几步路。我们省了多少钱？够了。足够让我们迷路了！或者你可以预订希尔顿酒店。欢迎来到你的海滨客房。离水边仅几步之遥。
The Hilton sale is on now. Book on Hilton.com or the Hilton app and save up to 20% to get the stay you expected. When you want savings, not surprises. It matters where you stay. Hilton, for the stay. Can you remember your first birthday party, or your first words, or the house you lived in when you were two? If you can't, and I bet you can't, why not?
希尔顿促销活动现已开启。在 Hilton.com 或希尔顿应用程序上预订，最高可享 8 折优惠，获得你期待的住宿体验。当你想要的是节省开支，而不是意外惊喜时。住哪里很重要。希尔顿，为你而住。你还记得你的第一个生日派对、你的第一句话，或者你两岁时住的房子吗？如果你不记得了，而且我敢说你肯定不记得，为什么呢？
The mystery of what scientists call childhood or infantile amnesia has long puzzled researchers. The infant brain is an amazing learning machine. It takes us from helpless newborns to walking, talking preschoolers in just a few years. but for some reason, virtually no memories of those formative years stick with us into adulthood. Today we're going to talk to a scientist who studies infant learning and memory. He has looked into why we don't remember our own earliest experiences. Are babies' brains forming memories at all? And if so, why can't we access them later in life?
科学家所说的童年或婴儿期遗忘症的谜团长期以来一直困扰着研究人员。婴儿的大脑是一台神奇的学习机器。它让我们在短短几年内从无助的新生儿变成了会走路、会说话的学龄前儿童。但出于某种原因，这些成长岁月中的记忆几乎没有留在我们的成年生活中。今天，我们将采访一位研究婴儿学习和记忆的科学家。他一直在研究为什么我们不记得自己最早的经历。婴儿的大脑真的在形成记忆吗？如果是这样，为什么我们在以后的生活中无法获取这些记忆？
How does the infant brain make sense of the world? What insights can studying infant learning and memory give us into learning and memory more? broadly? And how are scientists using new brain imaging tools and techniques to explore all of these questions? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Nicholas Turk Brown, a professor of psychology and director of the Wu Tsai Institute at Yale University. He studies how adults, children, and babies perceive the world and how we learn from experience and store information in memory.
婴儿的大脑是如何理解世界的？研究婴儿的学习和记忆能为我们更广泛地理解学习和记忆提供什么见解？科学家们如何利用新的脑成像工具和技术来探索所有这些问题？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我今天的嘉宾是耶鲁大学心理学教授、吴蔡研究所所长尼古拉斯·特克·布朗博士。他研究成人、儿童和婴儿如何感知世界，以及我们如何从经验中学习并将信息存储在记忆中。
His lab has pioneered techniques for brain imaging and infants and toddlers. His work has been published in leading journals and featured in major news outlets, including the New York Times, and the Atlantic. He's received Young Investigator Awards from APA, as well as from the Vision Sciences Society, the Cognitive Neuroscience Society, and the Society of Experimental Psychologists, and he recently received the Trolland Research Award from the National Academy. of Sciences. Dr. Turk Brown, thank you for joining me today. Thank you for having me, Kim. What is the earliest age that most people can remember? Now, some people claim to be able to
他的实验室率先开发了针对婴儿和幼儿的脑成像技术。他的研究成果发表在领先的期刊上，并被《纽约时报》和《大西洋月刊》等主要新闻媒体报道。他获得了美国心理学会（APA）以及视觉科学学会、认知神经科学学会和实验心理学家学会颁发的青年研究者奖，最近还获得了美国国家科学院颁发的特罗兰研究奖。特克·布朗博士，感谢您今天加入我的节目。谢谢你的邀请，金。大多数人能记得的最早年龄是多少？现在，有些人声称能够
remember things from their babyhood or very early toddlerhood. Is that even possible? Well, to figure out what early memories people have, scientists sometimes will conduct surveys or poll adults about what they remember from early in life. And typically the earliest memories that people report are around four to five years old and up. Importantly, that's regardless of how old you currently are. So if you're 20 years old, that's true. If you're 70 years old, that's true. There's a period of the first few years of life that we are largely amnesiac about. I never say never. People sometimes report early memories and they may be real. But the science suggests that memories from before that period, before three or four years old, are unlikely to be sort of
记得他们婴儿时期或幼儿早期的事情。这真的可能吗？嗯，为了弄清楚人们有什么早期记忆，科学家有时会进行调查或民意测验，询问成年人他们记得生命早期的什么事情。通常，人们报告的最早记忆大约在四五岁左右。重要的是，这与你现在的年龄无关。所以如果你 20 岁，这是真的。如果你 70 岁，这也是真的。生命最初的几年里，我们基本上处于遗忘状态。我从不说绝对。人们有时会报告早期记忆，它们可能是真实的。但科学表明，那个时期之前，也就是三四岁之前的记忆，不太可能是
pure memories that you're recollecting from a specific moment in your life. You know, you talked about asking basically people who are adults how far back they can remember. But what if you talk to a seven-year-old or a five-year-old? Can they remember being one or two? Yeah, sometimes they can. I can say that from personal experience. I can also say we are currently helped curate an exhibit at the Peabody Museum in New Haven where there's a station where people can write or draw their first memories. And it's a wonderful exhibit and station just to see kids interacting with their parents talking about their early life. And so I think it's possible and scientifically understudied for how long in childhood can we retain early experiences and memory.
你从生命中某个特定时刻回忆起的纯粹记忆。你知道，你谈到询问成年人他们能记得多远以前的事情。但如果你问一个七岁或五岁的孩子呢？他们能记得自己一岁或两岁时的事情吗？是的，有时他们能。我可以从个人经验中说这一点。我还可以说，我们目前正在协助策划纽黑文皮博迪博物馆的一个展览，那里有一个展台，人们可以在那里写下或画出他们的第一段记忆。这是一个很棒的展览和展台，可以看到孩子们与父母互动，谈论他们的早期生活。所以我认为这是可能的，而且关于我们在童年时期能保留早期经历和记忆多久，科学界的研究还不够。
I don't know for sure that we know the answer to that question because often people don't have ground truth about what was actually experienced early in life that they can go back to and verify whether a memory was accurate or not. And so that's where the scientific research comes in to try to establish on firmer ground that a memory is authentic and accurate. Well, let's talk about the question I asked in the introduction just a few moments ago. Do we make memories as babies that we just can't access when we get older? Or do babies not form memories at all, at least not in the same way that adults do? Yeah, this is a profound and fascinating question that I think we have all thought about in one way or another,
我不确定我们是否知道这个问题的答案，因为人们往往没有关于生命早期实际经历的“基本事实”，无法回头去验证记忆是否准确。所以这就是科学研究的切入点，试图在更坚实的基础上确定记忆是真实且准确的。好吧，让我们谈谈我在几分钟前的介绍中提出的问题。我们作为婴儿时是否制造了记忆，只是在长大后无法获取？还是说婴儿根本没有形成记忆，至少不像成年人那样形成记忆？是的，这是一个深刻而迷人的问题，我想我们都以某种方式思考过，
as parents and as people thinking back on our early lives. I mean, this has fascinated scientists for more than a century. Freud popularized the idea of infantile amnesia and had his own ideas about it that are not accepted today. But basically, there are two general kinds of explanations, which you're alluding to. One is that maybe the infant's mind and brain are immature and unable to store durable. memories. And so our lack of memories later in life are because there's nothing available for us to pull up. The other possibility is that the infant brain is storing memories and that over time we lose access to those memories. And in some abstract sense, they may still be there in the brain
作为父母，作为回顾我们早期生活的人。我的意思是，一个多世纪以来，这一直让科学家们着迷。弗洛伊德普及了婴儿遗忘症的概念，并有他自己今天已不被接受的观点。但基本上，有两种普遍的解释，也就是你提到的那些。一种是婴儿的心智和大脑可能还不成熟，无法存储持久的记忆。所以我们后来生活中缺乏记忆是因为没有可供我们调取的东西。另一种可能性是婴儿大脑正在存储记忆，而随着时间的推移，我们失去了对这些记忆的访问权限。在某种抽象意义上，它们可能仍然存在于大脑中，
if we could access them somehow. And so these are the two sort of classic hypotheses about infantile amnesia, the first having to do with a failure of encoding or storing a memory, the second having to do with a failure of retrieval of being able to access the memory. And this is a longstanding question, but really excitingly, there's been amazing scientific progress in the last few years that have shed light on this question. The most compelling recent research actually has come from animal studies in rodents. So to walk you through that briefly, imagine that you have a baby mouse and you give them some kind of memory. So for example, you put them in a maze and they have to learn how to escape from the maze.
如果我们能以某种方式获取它们的话。所以这就是关于婴儿遗忘症的两种经典假设，第一种与编码或存储记忆的失败有关，第二种与检索的失败有关，即无法访问记忆。这是一个长期存在的问题，但令人兴奋的是，过去几年里科学取得了惊人的进展，为这个问题提供了启示。最近最引人注目的研究实际上来自啮齿动物的动物研究。简单地带你了解一下，想象你有一只小老鼠，你给它们某种记忆。例如，你把它们放在迷宫里，它们必须学习如何逃离迷宫。
If you then let that mouse grow up, and in the case of a mouse, that's not 18 years, that's 20 weeks or so. and you put the mouse back in that same maze, they won't remember how to escape. That is, they show something like infantal amnesia. They don't remember something they learned early in their life. So the recent research, though, used very fancy modern molecular methods to figure out how the initial infant mouse's memory had been stored.
如果你让那只老鼠长大，对于老鼠来说，那不是 18 年，而是 20 周左右。然后你把老鼠放回同一个迷宫，它们不会记得如何逃脱。也就是说，它们表现出类似于婴儿遗忘症的症状。它们不记得自己生命早期学到的东西。然而，最近的研究使用了非常先进的现代分子方法来弄清楚最初小老鼠的记忆是如何存储的。
And then after the mouse had grown up, to stimulate the neurons that were part of that memory. And they do this using a technique called optogenetics, where you shine light on neurons, and it causes them to become active. So if you knew what neurons had stored a baby memory, and then you could activate those neurons in adulthood, what they found in these studies
然后在老鼠长大后，刺激那些作为记忆一部分的神经元。他们使用一种称为光遗传学的技术来做到这一点，即用光照射神经元，使其变得活跃。所以如果你知道哪些神经元存储了婴儿记忆，然后你就能在成年期激活这些神经元，他们在这些研究中发现
is that even though the mouse couldn't remember how to escape from the maze normally, if you activated the memory through this kind of stimulation, then the mouse remembered and could escape. And so what this suggested was that actually the memory was there. It's just being back in the environment wasn't sufficient to access it. It needed to be directly stimulated. Now, we can't do that in humans.
的是，即使老鼠通常不记得如何逃离迷宫，如果你通过这种刺激激活了记忆，那么老鼠就会记得并能够逃脱。这表明实际上记忆是存在的。只是回到环境中不足以获取它。它需要被直接刺激。现在，我们不能在人类身上这样做。
And I can tell you about the work in my lab that's trying to get at a similar question. But that evidence is suggestive of more of a retrieval explanation for infantomnesia that we may have latent forgotten memories that are still there in some fashion in our brain. And is the reason we can't do it in humans because we basically have to open up their heads and go into their brains and start stimulating? Yeah, indeed. But there's a couple of reasons. The tricks to sort of tag which neurons were part of a memory require, you know, genetic and other sort of molecular tools that are not safer or ethical in humans. And the other is to stimulate neurons in the brain, deep down in the brain in the brain region that's really essential for this kind of memory called the hippocampus, you'd have to open up somebody's head. That's done in certain clinical conditions, for example, in neurosurgery for epilepsy. But for basic science studies, that kind of research where you knew what neurons were active in a baby's brain and then you stimulate them in adults is not currently possible in humans.
我可以告诉你我实验室里试图解决类似问题的工作。但这些证据暗示了婴儿遗忘症更多是一种检索解释，即我们可能有一些潜在的、被遗忘的记忆，它们以某种方式仍然存在于我们的大脑中。我们不能在人类身上这样做是因为我们基本上必须打开他们的头颅，进入他们的大脑并开始刺激吗？是的，确实如此。但有几个原因。标记哪些神经元是记忆一部分的技巧需要基因和其他分子工具，这些在人类身上是不安全或不道德的。另一个原因是刺激大脑深处，即对这种记忆至关重要的海马体区域，你必须打开某人的头颅。这在某些临床条件下是可以做到的，例如癫痫的神经外科手术。但对于基础科学研究，那种你知道婴儿大脑中哪些神经元活跃，然后在成年后刺激它们的研究，目前在人类身上是不可能的。
Some people think that you can hypnotize people and regress them back far enough to retrieve these memories. Is that scientific in any way at all, or is that just a lot of hocus pocus? My initial reaction is hocus pocus, but what I will say is that it's absolutely true that one thing that helps us to recall forgotten memories is to put us back in the same sort of mindset or context that we were when we initially encoded the memory. This is the idea of context that when you store a memory, it's not only stored in terms of the content of what you're experiencing, maybe the people out of birthday party or what flavor the cake was and so on, but also kind of where you were in space, what time of day or what time of year it was, what's going on in the world and so on. So our memories are deeply embedded and the context in which we experience them. And it absolutely is a very effective strategy to kind of guide yourself or other people back to the same mindset in order to prompt retrieval. I don't know that hypnosis is particularly good or bad at doing this.
有些人认为你可以催眠人们并让他们退行到足够远的时间来检索这些记忆。这在科学上有任何依据吗，还是仅仅是江湖骗术？我最初的反应是江湖骗术，但我会说，有一件事确实有助于我们回忆起被遗忘的记忆，那就是让我们回到最初编码记忆时的那种心态或情境中。这就是情境的概念，当你存储记忆时，它不仅是根据你所经历的内容存储的，比如生日派对上的人或蛋糕是什么味道等等，还包括你在空间中的位置、一天中的时间或一年中的时间、世界上正在发生什么等等。所以我们的记忆深深植根于我们经历它们的情境中。引导自己或其他回到同样的心态来提示检索，这绝对是一个非常有效的策略。我不知道催眠在做这件事上是否特别好或特别坏。
But, you know, this is the classic, you know, if you're trying to find your keys, think about where you've been today. And so we do this ourselves, and professional memory athletes do this as well using techniques like the method of loci where you sort of trace steps in your mind to reconstruct how things had been stored. So there's some truth to that. Whether it's possible to provide contextual cues in an older child or an adult that would help them sort of get back into the same state they were in as a baby is a much more challenging question. So what happens to the memories that babies might be forming? I mean, where are they, and if they exist somewhere in the brain, could they somehow be retrieved? Prior to our research on this topic, which used functional magnetic resonance imaging, most research on infant memory was behavioral research. And so there's very clever
但是，你知道，这是经典的例子，如果你在找钥匙，想想你今天去过哪里。所以我们自己也会这样做，专业的记忆运动员也会使用诸如“轨迹法”之类的技术，在脑海中追踪步骤来重建事物是如何存储的。所以这其中有一些道理。是否有可能在较大的孩子或成年人身上提供情境线索，帮助他们回到婴儿时期的状态，这是一个更具挑战性的问题。那么婴儿可能形成的记忆发生了什么？我的意思是，它们在哪里，如果它们存在于大脑的某个地方，它们能以某种方式被检索吗？在我们关于这个主题的研究（使用功能性磁共振成像）之前，大多数关于婴儿记忆的研究都是行为研究。因此，几十年来，发展心理学研究中出现了非常巧妙的
paradigms for several decades now in developmental psychology research to try to get at memory in babies. This is very challenging. We can't ask a baby, what do you remember? Most of the babies under a year or are preverbal and unable to answer that question or even maybe understand what the question is. And so you have to use indirect behavioral methods. So Rovi Collier and And many others have developed really ingenious methods for measuring memory based on what babies look at, how they move their bodies and so on. And so that's one way of studying baby memory. And when you do that, you see that there's a transition somewhere around 9 to 12 months old where babies seem to be able to start forming memories that can be expressed in these indirect forms of behavior. So our research really asked the question, well, what is the nature of an infant's memory abilities?
范式来试图获取婴儿的记忆。这非常具有挑战性。我们不能问婴儿，你记得什么？大多数一岁以下的婴儿还处于前语言阶段，无法回答这个问题，甚至可能不理解这个问题是什么。所以你必须使用间接的行为方法。罗维·科利尔和许多其他人开发了非常巧妙的方法，根据婴儿看什么、如何移动身体等来测量记忆。所以这是研究婴儿记忆的一种方式。当你这样做时，你会发现 9 到 12 个月大左右有一个过渡期，婴儿似乎开始能够形成可以以这些间接行为形式表达的记忆。所以我们的研究确实提出了一个问题，婴儿的记忆能力本质是什么？
We know from adult research that memory is not one thing. It means several different things. There are five or six different brain systems that are involved in storing memories in different ways. So, for example, a really critical brain structure is the hippocampus, which is deep in the brain. This is the structure that was resected in the famous patient, Henry Maliason, H.M. It was removed surgically in his case, and he lost his ability to store what are called episodic memories, memories for specific events that happened at some location at some moment. So that's one example of a memory system. There are other brain systems like the amygdala that are involved in storing emotional memories, the cerebelly, cerebellum that's involved in storing motor memories, the striatum or the basoganglia that seem to be
我们从成人研究中知道，记忆不是单一的东西。它意味着几种不同的东西。有五六种不同的脑系统以不同的方式参与存储记忆。例如，一个非常关键的大脑结构是海马体，它位于大脑深处。这就是在著名的病人亨利·莫莱森（H.M.）身上被切除的结构。在他的案例中，它是通过手术切除的，他失去了存储所谓“情景记忆”的能力，即对发生在某个地点、某个时刻的特定事件的记忆。所以这是一个记忆系统的例子。还有其他大脑系统，如参与存储情绪记忆的杏仁核，参与存储运动记忆的小脑，似乎参与存储奖励相关记忆的纹状体或基底神经节。
involved in storing reward-related memories. And so really when you're measuring an infant's behavior, you don't know which of these brain structures or perhaps other developing brain structures might be responsible for what infants can start remembering. And so our research using functional MRI was able to look under the hood and say, what's happening in a baby's brain when memories are being formed? And we focused on the hippocampus in particular because it's deep in the brain. It's in adults, the only way to access it, you know, through brain imaging is with functional MRI. A part of my lab focuses on adults.
所以当你测量婴儿的行为时，你不知道这些大脑结构中的哪一个，或者其他正在发育的大脑结构，可能对婴儿开始记住的东西负责。因此，我们使用功能性磁共振成像（fMRI）的研究能够深入内部，观察婴儿大脑在形成记忆时发生了什么。我们特别关注海马体，因为它位于大脑深处。在成年人中，通过脑成像访问它的唯一方法是使用功能性磁共振成像。我的实验室的一部分专注于成人。
So we naively at the time thought, well, why don't we do functional MRI experiments in babies? It's safe. If MRI has been used in babies for a long time, but they're almost always asleep. And the reason is that babies are not good participants for functional MRI studies. You have to stay completely still. It's like taking a photograph at night if you move. The image is blurry. And usually you need to collect, you know, an hour or two hours of data in order to find the signal and the noise.
所以我们当时天真地想，为什么我们不做婴儿的功能性磁共振成像实验呢？它是安全的。如果磁共振成像在婴儿身上已经使用了很长时间，但他们几乎总是睡着的。原因是婴儿不是功能性磁共振成像研究的好参与者。你必须完全静止。这就像在晚上拍照，如果你移动了，图像就会模糊。通常你需要收集一两个小时的数据才能在噪声中找到信号。
But babies have short attention span of a few minutes if you're lucky. And so we had to develop techniques to figure out how to do these sorts of experiments and infants. But when we did, we were able to study the hippocampus, and we showed that beginning around one year of age, the infant hippocampus is participating in the storage of episodic memories that last for at least a few minutes. Overall, we saw this across our whole age range from sort of three months to two years. but the effects were strongest in babies starting around one year of age where greater activity, brain activity in the hippocampus when they were experiencing something new was associated with better memory later on. Now, we measured their memory, in this case based on increased looking at things they were
但婴儿的注意力跨度很短，如果幸运的话只有几分钟。所以我们必须开发技术来弄清楚如何对婴儿进行这些实验。但当我们这样做时，我们能够研究海马体，我们证明从一岁左右开始，婴儿海马体就开始参与存储至少持续几分钟的情景记忆。总的来说，我们在从三个月到两岁的整个年龄范围内都看到了这一点。但效果在开始一岁左右的婴儿身上最强，当他们经历新事物时，海马体中更大的大脑活动与以后的更好记忆相关联。现在，我们测量他们的记忆，在这种情况下是基于对他们熟悉事物的增加注视。
familiar with. So that's one clue that actually the core memory functions of the brain involved in episodic memory, those basic mechanisms for storing these really rich memories that we can feel nostalgic about and reflect on that that sort of core machinery may be coming online around one year of age. What we know, we published this work a couple of months ago, and it's really opened up a lot of questions because as we talked about at the beginning, people don't tend to report many memories before age four or five, but the machinery seems to be starting to work around age one. And so what happens to those memories that are formed, you know, one, two, three years old that makes them inaccessible? And we have different ideas about why that might be that we're starting to test.
所以这是一个线索，实际上大脑中参与情景记忆的核心记忆功能，那些存储我们能感到怀旧和反思的丰富记忆的基本机制，那种核心机制可能在一岁左右开始上线。我们知道，我们几个月前发表了这项工作，它确实引发了很多问题，因为正如我们在开头谈到的那样，人们在四五岁之前往往报告不了多少记忆，但机制似乎在一岁左右就开始工作了。那么那些在一、二、三岁时形成的记忆发生了什么，使它们无法访问？我们对为什么会这样有不同的想法，我们正在开始测试。
I have to ask, how do you keep a one-year-old baby still enough to do an fMRI? You know, I still have a lot of imposter syndrome as a developmental psychologist. I trained as a cognitive psychologist, which is a blessing and a curse because I was naive and foolish enough to want to try this. And I convinced some really adventurous graduate students to help me with this. So Cameron Ellis was one of my first graduate students, who's now a professor at Stanford. And the lead on this memory study that I was talking about is Tristan Yates. She's now a postdoc at Columbia University. And we have a large team of students and postdocs who have been working on these projects. So there's no short answer other than a lot of trial and error, almost over a decade of efforts now.
我必须问，你是如何让一岁大的婴儿保持足够静止来做 fMRI 的？你知道，作为一名发展心理学家，我仍然有很多冒名顶替综合症。我受过认知心理学家的训练，这既是福也是祸，因为我当时天真且愚蠢到想尝试这个。我说服了一些非常有冒险精神的研究生来帮助我。所以卡梅伦·埃利斯是我最早的研究生之一，他现在是斯坦福大学的教授。我正在谈论的这项记忆研究的负责人是特里斯坦·耶茨。她现在是哥伦比亚大学的博士后。我们有一个由学生和博士后组成的大型团队一直在从事这些项目。所以除了大量的反复试验，没有简短的答案，现在已经有近十年的努力了。
I started with the thought that we needed to engineer some really clever solutions for this. But as I should have known, it actually all comes down to the soft stuff. Having parents feel really comfortable, getting them to participate in the research to help in the procedures, setting up the scanner environment to be really comfortable for the baby, having them bring comfort items like pacifiers and blankies and stuffies, giving them bottles and snacks during the scans. You know, I have found goldfish hiding in our MRI room. It's really variable. In some ways, it's not what you want in science because no two sessions are alike.
我最初认为我们需要为这个问题设计一些非常巧妙的解决方案。但正如我应该知道的那样，实际上一切都归结于“软性”的东西。让父母感到非常舒适，让他们参与研究以协助程序，将扫描仪环境设置得对婴儿非常舒适，让他们带上安抚奶嘴、毯子和毛绒玩具等舒适物品，在扫描过程中给他们喂奶和零食。你知道，我曾在我们的 MRI 室里发现过金鱼饼干。这真的很不稳定。在某些方面，这不是你想要的科学，因为没有两次会议是相同的。
We've scanned. We've done probably closer more than 400 of these sessions now, and I don't think any two of them are the same. So this is not repeatable science, but this is very adaptive, flexible science where we find ways to keep the baby happy and comfortable long enough to engage them in some short and statistically powerful tasks to get enough data to do something. And it's now feasible. It's not easy. But before us, there were a couple of groups who were doing this kind of work, Jez-Zen-Dahan Lambertz in Paris and Rebecca Sachs at MIT. and others. I've been pioneering these methods. And so this is a growing field. I think it's extraordinarily exciting. There are unlimited questions about the baby's mind where by looking
我们已经扫描了。我们现在可能已经完成了超过 400 次这样的会议，我不认为有两次是相同的。所以这不是可重复的科学，但这是非常适应性强、灵活的科学，我们找到方法让婴儿保持快乐和舒适足够长的时间，让他们参与一些简短且具有统计学意义的任务，以获得足够的数据来做点什么。现在这已经可行了。这并不容易。但在我们之前，有几个小组在做这种工作，巴黎的 Jez-Zen-Dahan Lambertz 和麻省理工学院的 Rebecca Sachs 等人。一直在开创这些方法。所以这是一个不断发展的领域。我认为这非常令人兴奋。关于婴儿的心智有无限的问题，通过观察
under the hood, you might be able to reveal something about how their mind works before they're able to express themselves or behave in more sophisticated ways. I'm glad you've assured our listeners that no babies were harmed during this research. Absolutely not. We started this research right around when I had my own babies. And although they were never formally participants in our studies, because that felt like a conflict of interest, they guided everything we did. And in fact, often babies are unhappy when they come out of the machine because they're looking at really interesting things.
内部，你也许能够揭示一些关于他们的心智在他们能够表达自己或以更复杂的方式表现之前是如何运作的。我很高兴你向我们的听众保证，这项研究中没有婴儿受到伤害。绝对没有。我们开始这项研究时，我自己的孩子刚出生。虽然他们从未正式成为我们研究的参与者，因为那感觉像是利益冲突，但他们指导了我们所做的一切。事实上，婴儿从机器里出来时往往不高兴，因为他们正在看非常有趣的东西。
And they're very comfortable. I'd say about a third of the time the babies fall asleep and have a nap after 10 or 15 minutes in there. So they're quite comfortable. And actually, we've had parents ask us, if we could just let them sleep a bit longer in the machine. Now, I mean, don't, but isn't there that really loud noise through the whole experience? Are they dealing with that?
而且他们非常舒服。我想大约三分之一的时间，婴儿在里面待了 10 或 15 分钟后会睡着并小睡一会儿。所以他们很舒服。事实上，有父母问我们，是否可以让他们在机器里多睡一会儿。现在，我的意思是，不要这样做，但整个过程中不是有那种非常大的噪音吗？他们能应付吗？
That's right. So MRI machines have a lot of moving parts, and they clang. And, you know, so one of the challenges early on was how to, I mean, the sounds trivial, but it took a couple years of work, how to apply hearing protection in a way that would be durable and safe and redundant. And so we came up with a system that involves three layers of hearing protection, and we can attenuate the sound levels down to everyday sound levels that a baby might encounter on a sidewalk or in daycare and so on. We know that it works because they don't startle when the machine turns on. They're quite comfortable, and babies are not shy about telling you when they're surprised about a noise.
没错。所以 MRI 机器有很多运动部件，它们会发出叮当声。你知道，所以早期的挑战之一是如何，我的意思是，这听起来很琐碎，但花了几年时间，如何以一种耐用、安全且冗余的方式应用听力保护。所以我们想出了一种涉及三层听力保护的系统，我们可以将声音水平衰减到婴儿在人行道或日托中心等地方可能遇到的日常声音水平。我们知道它有效，因为当机器启动时他们不会惊吓。他们很舒服，婴儿在对噪音感到惊讶时不会害羞地告诉你。
And so that part's working quite well. And really excitingly, we just developed with a company noise canceling, headphones for babies. In the past, we've used a lot of hearing protection to make sure that the machine noise wasn't too loud. But now we have headphones that can play sound, so it's not just silent to them. And we can look at really interesting questions around language and multisensory processing and so on. So we're still evolving our techniques, but that's a great example of something that seems not especially technical or sophisticated, but that makes all the difference for their comfort. We're going to take a short break. And when we come back, we'll
所以那部分工作得很好。非常令人兴奋的是，我们刚刚与一家公司开发了婴儿降噪耳机。过去，我们使用了很多听力保护措施来确保机器噪音不会太大。但现在我们有了可以播放声音的耳机，所以对他们来说不仅仅是静音。我们可以研究关于语言和多感官处理等非常有趣的问题。所以我们仍在改进我们的技术，但这是一个很好的例子，说明了一些看起来不是特别技术性或复杂的东西，但对他们的舒适度却产生了巨大的影响。我们要休息一下。当我们回来时，我们将
We'll talk to Dr. Turk Brown about what else brain imaging research might be able to tell us about how babies experience the world and what it's like to be a baby. It's peak pollination season and my business is scaling fast. To keep the nectar flowing, I need a phone plan with top priority data speeds. That's why I chose GoogleFi wireless. My connections stay strong even when the hive is buzzing. Plus, unlimited plans started $35 a month. Now that's a deal that doesn't stay. Explore GoogleFi Wireless plans today. Plus taxes and government fees.
我们将与特克·布朗博士谈谈脑成像研究还能告诉我们关于婴儿如何体验世界以及作为婴儿是什么感觉。现在是授粉高峰期，我的业务扩展很快。为了保持花蜜流动，我需要一个具有最高优先级数据速度的电话套餐。这就是我选择 GoogleFi Wireless 的原因。即使在蜂窝繁忙时，我的连接也保持强劲。此外，无限套餐每月 35 美元起。这真是一个不会停留的交易。立即探索 GoogleFi Wireless 套餐。外加税费和政府费用。
GoogleFi Wireless is not subject to data traffic deprioritization during times of high network usage. Have you ever rearranged your furniture and discovered the carpet underneath looks brand new, while the rest of it looks, well, not so new? It's time for a carpet upgrade. At the Home Depot, we have stylish choices at simple prices from all the top brands. Best of all, we can install it for you, starting at only 49. cents per square foot. So all you have to do is pick your perfect floor. Start your carpet project today at the Home Depot. How doers get more done. Exclusions apply for licenses see Home Depot.com slash license numbers. What else might brain imaging research be able to tell us about how babies
GoogleFi Wireless 在网络使用率高时不受数据流量优先级降低的影响。你有没有重新布置过家具，发现下面的地毯看起来焕然一新，而其余部分看起来，嗯，没那么新？是时候升级地毯了。在家得宝（The Home Depot），我们有来自所有顶级品牌的时尚选择，价格简单。最棒的是，我们可以为你安装，每平方英尺仅需 49 美分起。所以你所要做的就是挑选你完美的地板。今天就在家得宝开始你的地毯项目。实干家完成更多工作。排除条款适用于许可证，请参阅 HomeDepot.com/license numbers。脑成像研究还能告诉我们关于婴儿
experience the world? I mean, could it give us insight into what it's like to be a baby and experience the world as a baby? Yeah, indeed. I mean, William James and others have had this idea that, you know, the infant's experience is really different, the blooming, buzzing confusion, and other ideas. And it's very hard, just like trying to study what a baby remembers. When you can't ask a baby, I mean, you can't give them a complex task, indirect measures, whether they be behavioral, looking time, or reaching behavior, whether they be based on brain measurements, are the only option. And so it's quite hard to know about the nature of an infant's experience.
体验世界？我的意思是，它能让我们深入了解作为婴儿是什么感觉以及像婴儿一样体验世界吗？是的，确实如此。我的意思是，威廉·詹姆斯和其他人有这样的想法，你知道，婴儿的体验确实不同，那种“绽放、嗡嗡作响的混乱”以及其他想法。这非常困难，就像试图研究婴儿记得什么一样。当你不能问婴儿时，我的意思是，你不能给他们复杂的任务，间接测量，无论是行为、注视时间还是伸手行为，无论是基于大脑测量，都是唯一的选择。所以很难了解婴儿体验的本质。
You know, Thomas Nagel, the philosopher, has this classic example of trying to understand what it would be like to be a different animal. Like, what does it feel like to be a bat with very different sensory systems, for example? And there's an analogous question in infants. What's it like to be a baby? It's hard for us, you know, philosophically to look at a baby as an adult and sort of understand than each other experience. But we can make some steps in that direction using advanced analysis approaches that have been developed. developed in adult cognitive neuroscience research to try to infer something about what baby experiences. So to give you one example, one of Tristan's other studies was looking at a phenomenon called event segmentation.
你知道，哲学家托马斯·内格尔有一个经典的例子，试图理解成为另一种动物会是什么感觉。例如，作为一种具有非常不同感官系统的蝙蝠是什么感觉？婴儿身上也有一个类似的问题。作为婴儿是什么感觉？作为成年人，我们在哲学上很难看着婴儿并理解彼此的体验。但我们可以使用在成人认知神经科学研究中开发的先进分析方法，朝着这个方向迈出一些步伐，试图推断出关于婴儿体验的一些东西。举个例子，特里斯坦的另一项研究是观察一种称为“事件分割”的现象。
And this is the idea that although we experience the world or the information we receive from the world is continuous, we're constantly flooded with sensory information. We experience the world actually in more discrete events. So, for example, Jeff Zox at Washu has a beautiful line of research over many years showing that if you present a movie to participants and you ask them to press a button when they feel like something has changed, like there's something has happened in the movie, there's something new happening. People press the button at basically the same time. That is, we perceive a continuous world in discrete ways. Our mind sort of carves up our experience into events. And this is, we perceive a continuous world in discrete ways. And this is, one way of asking about infant experience. Do they experience the world in events or in the more James kind of ideas is all an undifferentiated mess, a jumble, a soup of experience? And so Tristan applied brain imaging methods that had been used to figure out when does the brain decide that a new event has started and apply that to infants watching a movie. And we had different ideas. So maybe
这就是这个想法，尽管我们体验世界或我们从世界接收的信息是连续的，我们不断被感官信息淹没。我们实际上以更离散的事件体验世界。例如，华盛顿大学的杰夫·佐克斯多年来有一系列美丽的研究表明，如果你向参与者展示一部电影，并要求他们在感到有什么变化时按下按钮，比如电影中发生了什么，有什么新事情发生。人们基本上在同一时间按下按钮。也就是说，我们以离散的方式感知连续的世界。我们的心智将我们的体验切割成事件。这是我们以离散的方式感知连续的世界。这是询问婴儿体验的一种方式。他们是以事件的形式体验世界，还是像詹姆斯那种想法一样，一切都是未分化的混乱，一种体验的杂烩、汤？所以特里斯坦应用了脑成像方法，这些方法曾被用来弄清楚大脑何时决定一个新事件已经开始，并将其应用于观看电影的婴儿。我们有不同的想法。所以也许
infants are just really the way they experience the world is just totally dependent on the outside world. If there's a loud noise or a bright light or color or something changes in the world, they immediately sort of pivot and they're reactive rather than having an inner narrative of what's going on in the movie. In adults, we can use these methods. You can see that they might separate events every minute or two. And so there's a question, do infants have kind of shorter, more reactive events? In fact, we found the opposite that infants tended to have more stable brain activity over time. They carved up watching an animated movie into fewer events.
婴儿体验世界的方式完全取决于外部世界。如果有巨大的噪音或明亮的光线或颜色或世界上的某些东西发生了变化，他们会立即转向，他们是反应性的，而不是对电影中发生的事情有内在的叙述。在成年人中，我们可以使用这些方法。你可以看到他们可能每分钟或两分钟就会分离事件。所以有一个问题，婴儿是否有更短、更具反应性的事件？事实上，我们发现了相反的情况，婴儿倾向于随着时间的推移有更稳定的大脑活动。他们将观看动画电影的过程切割成更少的事件。
They seemed to integrate more over time and have longer time scale experiences. So that's a question about the perception of time, about the continuity of experience. It wasn't noisier. It was just longer. And so that's the kind of thing we can do. There are other techniques for brain decoding where you could try to. to figure out, well, here's what a baby's looking at, but what is being processed in different parts of the brain, and we can use machine learning or other AI-like techniques to infer the content
他们似乎随着时间的推移整合得更多，并且有更长时间尺度的体验。所以这是一个关于时间感知、关于体验连续性的问题。它并不嘈杂。它只是更长。所以这就是我们可以做的事情。还有其他大脑解码技术，你可以尝试弄清楚，好吧，这是婴儿正在看的东西，但大脑的不同部分正在处理什么，我们可以使用机器学习或其他类似人工智能的技术来推断
of what they're experiencing. So, yeah, there's many possibilities in that direction. Ultimately, it's going to be hard to validate that that's the conscious experience of the baby, without being the baby, but at least we can start to reveal some of what might be the contents of their experience. Where is that moment when you say, aha, that's a memory. The baby just remembered something. How do you know? Because you're showing different images.
他们正在体验的内容。所以，是的，在这个方向上有许多可能性。最终，如果不成为婴儿，很难验证这就是婴儿的意识体验，但至少我们可以开始揭示他们体验的内容可能是什么。当你问“啊哈，那是一个记忆”时，那个时刻在哪里？婴儿刚刚记住了什么。你怎么知道？因为你正在展示不同的图像。
The kid's in an fMRI machine, right? So you're not able to do eye tracking, right? I mean, the child is in there. So how do you know, bingo, there's a memory? Yeah. So in this case, we are doing eye tracking in the machine. Yeah. So I didn't mention it, but there's an MRI safe camera that's positioned over their face.
孩子在 fMRI 机器里，对吧？所以你不能做眼动追踪，对吧？我的意思是，孩子在里面。所以你怎么知道，宾果，那里有一个记忆？是的。在这种情况下，我们正在机器里进行眼动追踪。是的。所以我没有提到它，但有一个 MRI 安全摄像头定位在他们的脸部上方。
So they're lying in the machine. And if anyone's ever had an MRI before for your head or your brain, you're lying on your back. And so that's where the babies are, too, and they're looking up and there's a screen over their face. And so that's where we're presenting the images that they're looking at. And there's a little camera sitting there that's tracking their eye movements. So we adopt a technique that's widespread in developmental psychology and infant cognition research called visual-paired comparison. So we'll present the baby with a series of individual images. It could be a photograph of a face, a dog toy, a landscape, a series of these individual images.
所以他们躺在机器里。如果有人以前做过头部或大脑的 MRI，你是仰卧的。所以婴儿也是这样，他们向上看，他们的脸上方有一个屏幕。所以这就是我们展示他们正在看的图像的地方。那里有一个小摄像头在追踪他们的眼球运动。所以我们采用了一种在发展心理学和婴儿认知研究中广泛使用的技术，称为“视觉配对比较”。所以我们会向婴儿展示一系列单独的图像。它可以是一张人脸的照片、一个狗玩具、一个风景，一系列这些单独的图像。
To test their memory for those images, after delay and after other images, we have test trials in which we present two images at the same time. So, for example, the face that they had seen before alongside another face that they hadn't seen before on the other side of the screen. And in this kind of a task, after they had only seen the face once before, we have. hypothesized that they would look more at the familiar face if they remembered it from before. If they didn't have a memory of seeing that face before, they should have no reason to look at one face more than the other. And so that's actually the behavior that we're measuring in that study, which is to measure how much they look at a repeated image on one of these test trials and then go back and say, what was happening on the brain for images where they showed the
为了测试他们对这些图像的记忆，在延迟和其他图像之后，我们有测试试验，我们在其中同时呈现两个图像。例如，他们之前见过的人脸，旁边是屏幕另一侧他们之前没见过的人脸。在这种任务中，在他们之前只见过一次人脸后，我们假设如果他们记得之前见过它，他们会更多地注视熟悉的人脸。如果他们没有之前见过那张脸的记忆，他们就没有理由注视一张脸多于另一张脸。所以这实际上就是我们在那项研究中测量的行为，即测量他们在这些测试试验中注视重复图像的程度，然后回头说，对于他们表现出
strong familiarity preference at the test. How did you get interested in studying this topic? As you mentioned, you're not a developmental psychologist by training. So what got you on the path of studying memory in babies? My lab started as a cognitive neuroscience lab focused on the adult or at least mature brain. And in particular, we're interested in trying to understand the coordination of different cognitive functions. In cognitive psychology, we often study different aspects of the mind separately.
强烈熟悉偏好的图像，大脑发生了什么。你是怎么对研究这个话题感兴趣的？正如你提到的，你不是受过训练的发展心理学家。那么是什么让你走上了研究婴儿记忆的道路？我的实验室最初是一个专注于成人或至少是成熟大脑的认知神经科学实验室。特别是，我们有兴趣试图理解不同认知功能的协调。在认知心理学中，我们经常分别研究心智的不同方面。
You might study perception or attention or memory. But ultimately, in the real world, all of these functions are intermixed. We remember what we perceive, and what we remember influences what we pay attention to or perceive. So we started in my lab studying the interaction of different brain systems in support of cognition. And so I've long been interested in how humans learn and remember. And this isn't a profound insight, or at least it's not a unique insight, but we were studying this in adults, and I think there's learning that happens throughout life. You know, I like to think that in my 40s.
你可能会研究感知、注意力或记忆。但最终，在现实世界中，所有这些功能都是混合在一起的。我们记住我们感知的，我们记住的东西影响我们注意或感知的东西。所以我的实验室开始研究不同大脑系统在支持认知方面的相互作用。所以我一直对人类如何学习和记忆很感兴趣。这不是一个深刻的见解，或者至少不是一个独特的见解，但我们是在成年人身上研究这个的，我认为学习发生在整个生命周期中。你知道，我喜欢认为在我 40 多岁时。
But if you're really interested in learning, you can't ignore the first couple years of life. This is this magical period of plasticity where we live. learn language effortlessly. We learn how to walk. We form social relationships, develop food preferences. Focusing just on adults, if you have an interest in learning and memory, is leaving, you know, a lot of the variance off the table. And so that's kind of how I approach this to say, well, I'm also interested in developmental change and so on. But even as a case study of saying, here is a brain of an infant that's learning in astronomically sophisticated fast ways. And what do we understand about how that works?
但如果你真的对学习感兴趣，你就不能忽视生命最初的几年。这是一个神奇的可塑性时期，我们生活在其中。毫不费力地学习语言。我们学习如何走路。我们形成社会关系，发展食物偏好。如果你对学习和记忆感兴趣，只关注成年人，就是留下了很多变量。所以这就是我处理这个问题的方式，说，嗯，我也对发展变化等感兴趣。但即使作为一个案例研究，说，这是一个正在以天文数字般复杂、快速的方式学习的婴儿大脑。我们对它是如何工作的了解多少？
We started from understanding how the adult brain learns and remembers. I talked before about some of the brain regions that are involved in that. And when I got interested in working with infants and toddlers, there just wasn't a lot of research on those brain regions. those are very well understood in adults, humans. They're very well understood in animals, both young animals and older animals. But there just wasn't a lot of research on memory systems in early human development.
我们从了解成年人的大脑如何学习和记忆开始。我之前谈到过一些参与其中的大脑区域。当我开始对研究婴儿和幼儿感兴趣时，关于这些大脑区域的研究并不多。在成年人中，这些区域被研究得非常透彻。在动物中，无论是幼年还是成年动物，它们也被研究得非常透彻。但在人类早期发育的记忆系统方面，研究确实不多。
And the reason is that most of them are deep in the brain, like the hippocampus, the amygdala, the stridum. They're far away from the surface of the brain. And most of the existing methods for measuring the infant brain used scalp-based measures like electroencephalography or EEG or functional near infrared spectroscopy, F-nears, and these are really powerful and good methods for measuring the cortical surface, but cannot resolve deep brain signals. So the shorter answer to your question is this is a fascinating period of life for learning and memory. And because of my training and
原因在于它们大多位于大脑深处，比如海马体、杏仁核和纹状体。它们远离大脑表面。目前大多数测量婴儿大脑的方法都使用基于头皮的测量手段，如脑电图（EEG）或功能性近红外光谱（fNIRS）。这些方法在测量大脑皮层表面方面非常强大且有效，但无法解析深层大脑信号。所以，对你问题的简短回答是：这是生命中学习和记忆的一个迷人阶段。由于我的训练和
background in adult cognitive neuroscience, I had expertise with the tools needed to measure the key brain systems in infants. Do you think that your findings have implications for parents or preschool teachers or anyone else who is interacting with very young children? I do. I mean, the research was done for basic science purposes, trying to understand, you know, the nature of early memory and memory in general. Memory is a fundamental part of who we are.
成人认知神经科学的背景，我具备了测量婴儿关键大脑系统所需的专业工具。你认为你的发现对父母、学前班老师或任何与幼儿互动的人有启示吗？我认为有。我的意思是，这项研究是出于基础科学的目的，试图了解早期记忆以及记忆本身的本质。记忆是我们身份的核心部分。
It's the basis of our personality, our relationships, or our expertise. peace, it's identity defining. And so I think in a basic science way, understanding how early experiences are learned and remembered is fundamental for understanding human nature. In a more applied way, I mean, I think parents are quite interested in understanding what they should do with their kids. I think about this all the time, even things like when you should take that that big vacation? Are they likely to remember going out to, you know, going out west if we go on a vacation before they're old enough? Do they remember, you know, meeting their great-grandparent or their grandparent who's since passed away? I think parenting often we try to, we put a lot of pressure on
它是我们个性、人际关系和专业知识的基础，它定义了身份。所以我认为，从基础科学的角度来看，了解早期经历是如何被学习和记忆的，对于理解人性至关重要。从更实际的角度来看，我认为父母非常关心他们应该如何对待孩子。我一直都在思考这个问题，甚至包括什么时候带孩子去度那个大假？如果我们去西部度假，而他们还不够大，他们能记住吗？他们能记住见到后来去世的曾祖父母或祖父母吗？我认为在育儿过程中，我们经常会给自己施加很大的压力，
ourselves to try to sculpts the experience of our kids in order to build the kind of people that we think we want them to be. And so I think this research suggests actually that even though we later in life don't remember those first few years. Actually, there are memories being formed that are influencing our identity and our behavior, even if we can't sort of consciously recollect them. So I think this emphasizes the sophisticated cognitive abilities of infants and of toddlers. And it suggests that we shouldn't think about memory as being a black hole for the first few years, but rather it's there, trying to understand where those memories go, how they get combined,
试图塑造孩子的经历，以培养我们心目中希望他们成为的那种人。所以我认为这项研究实际上表明，尽管我们在以后的生活中不记得最初的那几年，但实际上，记忆正在形成，并影响着我们的身份和行为，即使我们无法有意识地回忆起它们。因此，我认为这强调了婴儿和幼儿复杂的认知能力。它表明我们不应该把记忆看作是前几年的黑洞，而应该认为它就在那里，试图了解这些记忆去了哪里，它们是如何结合的，
and how they influence their behavior. Those are some of the questions that we're working on. So, yeah, that's the short answer. A slightly longer answer, you know, I won't go on too long, but just to say that many of the core things that we want kids to learn in more of a daycare or a school setting are being learned via these memory systems. You talk about language acquisition or learning about concepts or categories, learning about social relationships, that learning happens in these brain regions. And so if we want to
以及它们如何影响他们的行为。这些就是我们正在研究的一些问题。所以，是的，这就是简短的回答。稍微长一点的回答是，我不会说太久，只是想说，我们希望孩子在日托或学校环境中学习的许多核心内容，都是通过这些记忆系统学习的。你谈到语言习得、学习概念或类别、学习社会关系，这些学习都发生在大脑的这些区域。所以如果我们想
understand both normative, how does the developing brain learn in an ideal case in a healthy way, also when things go awry in development, either early on or later, how does that impact knowledge and skills, language delays, and so on. If we had a better understanding of the underlying brain systems that absorb our experiences and build memories, that might point to some potential ways of either diagnosing or treating developmental disorders in the long run. So what's next? I mean, are you continuing the same line of research? Are you expanding, moving into other areas? The study that I referenced before, which was published in science in March, is a starting point. This is showing that infants have the capacity.
了解规范性发育（即大脑在理想和健康的情况下如何学习），以及当发育出现偏差时（无论是早期还是后期）如何影响知识、技能、语言迟缓等，如果我们能更好地理解吸收经历并建立记忆的底层大脑系统，这可能会为长期诊断或治疗发育障碍提供一些潜在途径。那么接下来呢？你是继续进行同一方向的研究，还是在扩展到其他领域？我之前提到的那项发表在三月份《科学》杂志上的研究是一个起点。这表明婴儿有能力
to form episodic memories in the hippocampus beginning around one year of age. Because we were doing both the encoding and the retrieval in the same study, it was only a few minutes before they were tested on their memory. So we know that they can store a memory, but we don't know how long it lasts. And this is a really critical question when we think about our lack of early memories. We're really talking years. It's our autobiography. And so it's an open question about how durable these early memories.
从一岁左右开始在海马体中形成情景记忆。因为我们在同一项研究中同时进行了编码和提取，他们在接受记忆测试前只有几分钟的时间。所以我们知道他们可以存储记忆，但我们不知道它能持续多久。当我们思考为什么我们缺乏早期记忆时，这是一个非常关键的问题。我们谈论的实际上是几年。这是我们的自传。所以这些早期记忆能持续多久还是一个悬而未决的问题。
might be, maybe that's part of the explanation. It's also unclear, if they are durable, why can't we access them? The mouse study I mentioned before suggests they're there, where I'm not suggesting we should go around stimulating the brains of humans to try to remember being a baby. But maybe we could figure out some clues from that mouse study. Just putting the mouse back in the maze wasn't enough to recall the memory. That is, the sensory cues, you know, the landmark in the environment, the geometry of the maze, maybe the smell of that room, that wasn't enough to pull up the memory. And I think something very much like that happens in us that as a baby, we have an experience. Maybe you go to a grandparents house and you're, I don't know, maybe a year
也许这就是部分解释。同样不清楚的是，如果它们是持久的，为什么我们无法获取它们？我之前提到的小鼠研究表明它们就在那里，我并不是建议我们应该去刺激人类的大脑来试图回忆起婴儿时期的事。但也许我们可以从那项小鼠研究中找到一些线索。仅仅把小鼠放回迷宫并不足以唤起记忆。也就是说，感官线索，比如环境中的地标、迷宫的几何形状，也许是那个房间的气味，这些都不足以提取记忆。我认为在我们身上也发生了非常类似的事情，作为一个婴儿，我们有一次经历。也许你去祖父母家，你当时，我不知道，也许一岁
old, and maybe you're sitting up or lying down. So you have a certain vantage of the environment you're in. You're hearing conversation, maybe parents and grandparents talking, but you don't really understand much of the language or you certainly don't understand the concepts being expressed, the narrative of the story. You're missing certain categories to make sense of the objects in your environment. But your hippocampus is storing a memory. That's what our findings suggest. So it's creating a snapshot of the sense that the rest of your brain is making of that experience. the hippocampus gets input from the cortex and just takes a sort of a picture of what the rest of the brain is processing. And now imagine you grow up when you're five years old or, you know, 20 years old and you go back to your grandparents' house.
大，也许你正坐着或躺着。所以你对所处的环境有一个特定的视角。你听到谈话，也许是父母和祖父母在交谈，但你并不真正理解大部分语言，或者你肯定不理解所表达的概念，不理解故事的叙述。你缺乏某些类别来理解环境中的物体。但你的海马体正在存储记忆。这就是我们的发现所暗示的。所以它正在为你大脑其余部分对该经历的理解创建一个快照。海马体从皮层接收输入，并拍摄下大脑其余部分正在处理的内容。现在想象一下，当你五岁或二十岁时，你回到祖父母家。
It might be the exact same room, the exact same people, if it's like my family, maybe the exact same arguments from 20 years ago. It's the same sensory information, but it's not calling up that infant experience that we had. And the hypothesis that we're pursuing is that it's because how the rest of the brain develops influences the input that the hippocampus gets. So now you can understand the conversation. You're taller and you're walking around, so you're seeing different things. You have certain concepts and categories they didn't have before. That becomes the input to the hippocampus. That's like what you're searching for in a search engine.
那可能是完全相同的房间，完全相同的人，如果像我的家庭一样，可能还有二十年前完全相同的争论。这是相同的感官信息，但它并没有唤起我们婴儿时期的经历。我们正在追求的假设是，这是因为大脑其余部分的发育方式影响了海马体接收到的输入。所以现在你可以理解谈话了。你长高了，四处走动，所以你看到了不同的东西。你拥有了以前没有的某些概念和类别。这成为了海马体的输入。这就像你在搜索引擎中搜索的内容一样。
Those are the terms that you're using to try to look up the memory. But that's not the content of your original memory because you couldn't make sense of what was happening. So the hypothesis there is that because of the development of the rest of the brain related to language and vision and concepts and thinking that actually there's a mismatch between how the memory was initially stored and how we're processing the retrieval cue. that could help us to pull up that memory. And there may be ways to trick that system and to sort of get back to some of the earlier cues. Maybe some cues like smells or faction might be more potent at retrieving these early memories
这些是你用来尝试查找记忆的术语。但这并不是你原始记忆的内容，因为你当时无法理解发生了什么。所以这里的假设是，由于大脑其余部分在语言、视觉、概念和思维方面的发展，实际上我们最初存储记忆的方式与我们处理提取线索的方式之间存在不匹配。这可能有助于我们提取那段记忆。而且可能有一些方法可以欺骗这个系统，并回到一些早期的线索。也许一些线索，比如嗅觉，在提取这些早期记忆时可能更有效，
because there's more consistency in how the brain processes them from early in life to later in life. Like Proust Madeline, right? The flavor of the cookie. But you're sure the memories are still there? Or is that something that you're really trying to ascertain? That's what we're working on. Yeah, trying to ascertain.
因为大脑从生命早期到晚期处理它们的方式更具一致性。就像普鲁斯特的玛德琳蛋糕一样，对吧？饼干的味道。但你确定记忆还在那里吗？还是说这正是你试图确定的？这就是我们正在努力的方向。是的，试图确定。
In some sense, they are absolutely there because memories are accrete. You know, you kind of build memories on top of memories. So language is a set of experiences that have been layered on top of each other. Our knowledge of our hometown or our childhood home. It might not be a specific memory of that time. I had a temper tantrum and ran up to my room and slammed the door and the turtle fell out of its aquarium, or, you know, very specific things. But I do remember in a general way where I lived and kind of how many bedrooms or house had. And so we have memories from early on, but really the deep question is, can I remember specific events from my life that happened when I was young? And we don't currently know whether those kinds of really specific episodic memories persist much beyond early
在某种意义上，它们绝对在那里，因为记忆是累积的。你知道，你是在记忆之上建立记忆。所以语言是一系列层层叠加的经历。我们对自己家乡或童年住所的了解。它可能不是那个时期的特定记忆。我发脾气跑进房间关上门，乌龟从水族箱里掉出来，或者非常具体的事情。但我确实记得我住在哪里，以及房子有多少个卧室。所以我们有早期的记忆，但真正深刻的问题是，我能记得我年轻时生活中发生的特定事件吗？我们目前不知道这些特定情景记忆是否能在早期之后持续很久，
childhood, although that's something we're working on in longitudinal studies. This is great work, Dr. Turk Brown. I want to thank you for joining me and telling our listeners all about what you're doing. Thank you so much for interest. I really appreciate it. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please follow us and leave a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Thank you for listening.
尽管这是我们正在纵向研究中探讨的问题。这项工作非常棒，Turk-Brown博士。我要感谢你加入我的节目，并向我们的听众介绍你的工作。非常感谢你的关注。我非常感激。你可以在我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org 或 Apple、Spotify、YouTube 或任何你获取播客的地方找到《心理学谈话》之前的剧集。如果你喜欢你所听到的，请关注我们并留下评论。如果你对未来的播客有意见或想法，可以发送电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由 Lee Weinerman 制作。感谢收听。
For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. Enjoy more ways to save at Ralph's, like low prices in every aisle. And when you download the Ralph's app, you can clip and save more with digital coupons every week. Plus, you can earn fuel points to save up to $1 per gallon at the pump. At Ralph's, you can enjoy more ways to save and more rewards every time you shop. So it's always easy to save big every day with savings and rewards. Ralph's SoCal for over 150 years. Savings may vary by state. Fuel restrictions apply. See site for details. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是美国心理学会的 Kim Mills。在 Ralph's 享受更多省钱方式，比如每个过道的低价。下载 Ralph's 应用程序，每周还可以通过数字优惠券剪辑并节省更多。此外，你还可以赚取燃油积分，在加油站每加仑节省高达 1 美元。在 Ralph's，你每次购物都能享受更多省钱方式和更多奖励。因此，通过储蓄和奖励，每天都能轻松省大钱。Ralph's SoCal 超过 150 年。储蓄可能因州而异。燃油限制适用。详情请见网站。此剧集尚无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。